dad yeah I was just wondering if you had
any advice for me going into the special
you know any advice that's three be
yourselves
wondering if you have any advice for me
[Music]
every time this is not what's up to
going well it's getting ready for
special so you for sure I'm not gonna be
able to make it to introduce me yeah do
you have any advice for me let's say
actually be funny on stage is always
funny and you're super funny at home
it's when he's trying to annoy me he
doesn't do the same the same thing
doesn't stick you fake a you're a
hundred percent sure you won't be able
to I'll be able to intro me huh all
right but no I guess you're up man
ladies and gentleman my dad Joshua
[Applause]
thank you very much for welcoming me
into this amazing city Boise has been
amazing you guys are so nice and so kind
unless somebody says the word Boise and
then you lose your [ __ ] minds but
we're not going to do that tonight but
thank you guys coming out and first
before I get started I did want to
address a few things somebody asked me
backstage they said their couple older
folks in here and do you change your
material for the age of the people who
are sitting in front of you no I want to
tell you why to my grandmother not that
notion out of me quick because the first
time she saw me I was super nervous I
didn't want to swear in front of her you
know
so she catches me backstage and she goes
you you looking nervous I said I am I'm
really nervous and she said why are you
so nervous I said well I don't want to
swear in front of you Nana
and she said what word exactly do you
not want to say I said well I don't want
to say [ __ ] in front of you and she said
sweetheart
I had to [ __ ] for you to get here and I
was like
to the show Leonarda giving you a ride
[ __ ] I need you in the side of the road
like my grandson needs to work you know
well here's thing with my grandparents
and I will say this I learned a lot from
them about family first of all they were
so funny
and they always infused humor into
whatever we doing and they never used
the word inappropriate if it was funny
it was funny and I was like me I'm gonna
do that and they also were all about
family first that was a big thing I
learned from my grandparents his family
first and I think I really took that
into my family with my kids you know my
my youngest son he tells me everything
everything he told me the first time he
touched the boot he walks into my room
super serious and he walks in he goes
hey I said what's up he goes boomer I
said what's going on he goes no no no no
no step outside now I'll tell you what I
thought was happening what I thought was
happening is I thought he hit that age
that everyman hits where they look at
their dad that first time and they think
I won't beat the [ __ ] out of this dude
but everybody looks down at least once
like oh tell me to take out the trash
again
so we're walking outside I'm tightening
up my shoe laces I'm like oh it's
[ __ ] on okay here we go
and I'm planning on just poking him in
the neck once really hard to slow him
down the [ __ ] you know cuz he's bigger
than me I need to slow him down he's a
big dude and we get outside and he goes
touch the boob and I say yeah what do
you think he goes whoa I'm definitely
gonna try to do that again so but now he
did try to fight me and I grew up with
three older brothers we all wrestled or
fought my dad at least once growing up
anybody in here wrestle or fight their
dad however you man held 12 not a lot of
muscle tone on a 12 year old 12 huh
how'd that go for you yeah you know what
you learned early on as a young man is
that your dad takes it way more
seriously than you do you right because
you're like I'm gonna mess with the old
man he's like you're like what the [ __ ]
yeah man I listen by the way I asked
some dude last week I go how old are you
and you fight your dad he goes thirty I
was like holy Sh
let's just beaten up an old man at that
point in time right but you know what he
said he goes yeah well it's the first
time I thought I had a shot so and I'm
not mad at him you going where you think
you got your shot you know but I
remember with my oldest brother the
first time he decided he was gonna fight
my dad right so me and my other two
brothers are in my room we're all under
the age of 10 I'm probably like six my
oldest brother's called like 16 and he
walks into the room super serious right
he walks in he's like I'm fighting dad
today and I'm six I'm like
you find dad that's right a button dad
you guys got my back and we were all
like you guys you guys ready for some
new rules like he goes what do you want
I'm like you got it like oh he was
riding with us up I thought there was
gonna be a regime change everybody I
needed to be on the right side of that
[ __ ] you know he had us riled up I was
grabbing pictures of my dad off the wall
like we're downstairs following him he's
like you guys ready like you guys got my
back we got your back we get outside my
dad's and the patio and he's smoking
cigars you're sitting down my brother
walks out and he goes we're fighting the
old man my dad stands up videos okay now
hindsight being what it is
my dad's confidence should have been a
bit of a red flag for my brother
dude didn't even take the cigar out of
his [ __ ] mouth he knew he wasn't
getting hit you don't I mean like if you
go to a fight and one of the guys has a
cigar in his mouth that's the [ __ ]
winner that's guys like I am confident
as [ __ ] so my brother goes and let me
tell you something and before he could
get another word out of his [ __ ]
mouth my dad kicked him in the nuts so
he fell on the ground
dad [ __ ] up to him he goes you know
you shouldn't talk to your fight right
and walk in the house like a [ __ ]
gangster and we all want
I'm not hanging outside with a loser I'm
going to South Africa winner like I'm
not stupid you know but he did try to
fight me so I'm walking into the kitchen
he's walking out and he leans his
shoulder in the I know uh did you just
lean your shoulder and he goes maybe you
should watch where you're going
I started laughing I go I'm sorry are
you starting to fight with me and he
goes yeah not that it's gonna be much of
a fight and I was like all right man
front lawn right now let's go
and he goes no no not now like three
weeks I'm like three who you [ __ ]
rock me when you need three weeks you
gotta turn some tires on really well he
was I gotta go look up some videos
online if I go now listen outwardly when
he said three weeks I was mocking him
but on the inside when he said three
weeks I was like you because I'm at an
age where I pull muscles and I bought
muscles doing [ __ ] and I shouldn't pull
a muscle doing like not too long ago I
pulled a muscle in my right shoulder uh
uh wiping my ass I went back to quick I
didn't touch my core it's all core
nowadays
when I went back to quit and all my wife
her but she walked by the door was oh no
listen guys if I get a stretch before I
[ __ ] you can kill me tonight do you know
what it's like if you walk into the
bathroom later and I'm like this and
you're like what are you doing man I'm
getting ready to prove like you can I
don't need to come out of the bathroom
you can kill me in there now you're
still by the way you couldn't do what my
dad did not this is this is definitely
something you could not get away with
now we have raised a different
generation of kids you guys know that
right we have raised a generation of
spoiled entitled [ __ ] you understand
that we can clap all you want but you
know whose fault it is
themselves guys it's our fault and we've
coddled them to the point or that it's
ridiculous
do you know that in a lot of states in
our great country they've outlawed
dodgeball do you know why because they
say humiliates the children Rab applause
by the way that's ironically why we
played the [ __ ] game to begin with
right whoo we made you cry today
right right applause people remember
playing dodgeball on the tables a place
of dodgeball who would place a dive bar
because we all have that sharing
experience right everybody in here
remember what that red rubber it tastes
like on your lips right hit and your
eyes are water and your nose starts to
run you try to get off the court nine
other balls hit you and your lady [ __ ]
[Applause]
they'll never have that experience
really
so I called my dad on the phone I know
my son wants to fight me I call him on
the phone I'm like hey man we all fought
you right he goes young and I said I
seem to remember you being a little more
violent than you need it to be and he
said no yeah you remember correctly and
I said why why why why and he goes with
listen man he wants to win right I said
yeah he said you have to win you have to
win because if you don't win the power
changes at your house and then you try
telling him to take out the trash
tomorrow he's gonna slap you in the face
and be like you take the trash out [ __ ]
don't make me [ __ ] you up again and I
was like oh my god he said this is how
and then he said something by the way
that I will never forget I go I have to
win he said Josh even if somebody ends
up calling the police
you have to win it and I was like oh now
listen I'm not a violent dude my dad was
more adept at that and now I did have
three older brothers so I am really good
at mental torture so I was like that's
kind of where I'll lean on so I hang up
the phone and I turn around and my wife
is there and she looks right at me she
goes are you fighting Jacob and I said
no no I'm not gonna fight him it's gonna
be something weird yourself in the front
law it's not gonna be like a fight
and she said why why don't you just tell
him that you're the grown-up and he's
the kid and that's it he does what you
say and I'm like nah I said that's not
gonna work and she said why I said I'm
not sure if you were there but he
basically slapped me in the face with
his dick in the kitchen like there's
only one response she goes I don't like
it I said I'm not saying it's the right
response I'm just saying it's the only
one that I know do you know and she said
I don't think this is a good idea and
then I maybe got a little too cocky and
I said I'll let you know when I have a
bad idea and she was like oh okay you're
gonna let me know and I said yeah and
she goes oh okay now listen you don't
have these problems with daughters like
I don't have that problem like what
daughter's challenged me to a fight the
only problem I ever had with my daughter
is that she's been smarter than me she's
she was six and like at the time when
we're sitting in our living room I
didn't understand a word that was coming
out of her mouth like we need my living
room I be like what's up baby she's like
oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god am I gonna date it's like
having a [ __ ] dolphin in my living
room right she tells me everything - she
came home one day she was like oh my god
that he can tell you something so
important oh my god okay that time I get
that he okay today oh my god oh my god
am I good today
my good buddy Chris tried to kiss me
and I was like oh my god
so what happened baby she said oh my god
Eddie I told him I wasn't sure if I was
allowed to do that I had to go home and
ask my daddy and I said you know babe
thank you very much for asking
look I know you're a teenager and your
hormones are running crazy and and you
don't know what do you know you it's
hard a hard time you know and the
hormones are up and they're down and
look I know it's a hard time and I'm not
got to tell you what to do with what not
to do cuz I don't think that's my job as
your father my job as your father is
just to tell you what I know and what I
know is is that God doesn't let little
hookers into heaven
[Applause]
do whatever you want to do that
information bad she's hanging around
teenage boys boys of a single biggest
predator that walked this planet earth
they're not in control of what's
happening here it's not there any man
that any guy in here will tell you
things used to pop up all the time for
no apparent reason
and it was confusing to us I remember
sitting in math class like and the
teacher always thought I was cheating I
was just checking to see if anybody else
was hard I'm like I guess nobody likes
geometry as much as I do teacher was
like mr. Wolfe you can leave math
classes over no I can't
picked a bad day to wear sweatpants is
all I'm gonna tell you me and the chick
who just gonna period for the first time
we're gonna hang out here a little while
you don't mind it terrible I'll tell you
something my daughter man you learned
really early on with her she is a
ride-or-die person if you are on her
team she is on your team for ever here's
what I knew there was no snitch in her
when I met my wife I was a single and I
was raising three kids right and my deal
she and I had both decided we were like
look it's not important for her to meet
the kids until we know we're gonna get
married because neither one of us
thought it was good for her to start a
relationship with them until we knew it
was a forever relationship for us right
so she used to come over after the kids
went to sleep and then she would go home
so one night it's late and she says to
me I don't I can't really drive home
tonight I'm too tired and I was like
well babe the first time the kids meet
you can't be tomorrow morning in my bed
that is not okay she said I know but I
don't know what to do and I said would
you want me to get you a car and then
I'll get your car back here tomorrow and
you can drive a car car home and she
said I'm just so tired she said do you
mind if I just sleep in your closet and
I was like so let me just see if I got
this right you're coming over and we're
dinner we're gonna have sex and then
you're gonna sleep in the closet she was
like yeah and I go okay yeah but so she
goes to sleep in the closet next morning
I'm up and my deal with the kids was I
make breakfast I make lunch you get
yourselves dressed so my daughter runs
in and I'm cooking breakfast and she
goes daddy I can't find my shoes and I
go babe you know I'm making breakfast I
can't help you out and she goes hey I
don't know where I looked everywhere and
I said you didn't look everywhere go
find the shoes
so about three minutes later she runs in
and she goes yeah I still can't find my
shoes and there's a stranger sleeping in
your closet and I go okay babe thank you
I said I'll help you find your shoes and
she goes okay I go just had a curiosity
Katie there's a stranger sleeping in my
closet that's the reaction I get and on
our way out of the kitchen she goes
it's your closet daddy I don't know what
happens in your brother when I was like
oh I'm gonna carry some body with that
girl thank you so I know I got to start
torturing my son right I called my
brother on the phone because I'm like
you guys tortured me endlessly what
should I do and he said what do you mean
all you talked about growing up was like
I wish I had a little brother so I could
do to him what you guys did to me he
goes now is your chance nobody gets to
go back and do that and I was like you
know you're you're right this is quite
an opportunity and he said yeah man do
you want me to send you over the list
and I go what list he goes oh the list
of things that we had that we used to do
to you
and I said why do you still have the
list and he was like you never know do
you
so he sends a list over right and I'm
looking at it and he said just remember
the most important thing is to start
small and go up from there so this all
started on a Sunday now listen he wants
three weeks I don't want to give him a
full three weeks I want to get this I
want to get him so mad my son that he
wants to fight at the end of the week I
need to get him so mad cuz that's the
only chance I have of beating him right
so my brother's like start slow okay so
Sunday night when my son is sleep and I
took all of his underwear out of his
drawer and I replaced it with panties
with the days of the week on
[Applause]
so when he woke up the next morning I'm
a cooking breakfast and I hear from the
other room I hear whoa
what is this hey these are my underwear
and I just yelled back hey just put your
Monday's on sunshine and come on out for
some back and he was like and I was like
don't say that don't say that don't say
that you're not fighting me hard
who has teenage boys knows the teenage
boys are dumb as [ __ ] so dumb so dumb
but even if you have a smart kid he is
dumb as [ __ ] both of my sons are smart
they are dumb dummy dumb dumbs Jacob had
some friends over once right 14 at the
time and all I hear is from the room oh
by the way every teenage boy sounds like
that
if you every teenage boy is a cross
between rocky and Forrest Gump like
every every teenage boy is somewhere
between no Adrienne and Jenny like
you're somewhere in that [ __ ] so all
I hear is ho ho ho ho I'm like what the
[ __ ] is going on in there
he's laughing for 15 minutes straight
right and I hear dad come in here come
in here so I go in there and for the
boys are on one bed with one of those
laser pointers that cats chase and the
other boys on a wall like this
[Music]
my son goes you should use that on stage
I'm like I'm gonna stupid they're easily
manipulated and they're just they don't
think because they're teenage this is my
son's one of his greatest ones right I
got an iPad for a gift and I didn't know
how to set it up so I gave it to him I
go man what you set this up for me I
don't know how to do it he was doing and
he brings it back later and he goes here
you go dad
all set up just so you know your iPad is
the cloud everything from everybody's
devices goes to your iPad everybody
hearing that everything from everybody's
devices my iPad so I'm scrolling through
pictures on the road seeing what I want
to post you know looking through you're
looking through we're looking through
and as a man when you're sitting on your
own bed looking at your own iPad looking
at your pictures you never want this
sentence to leave your mouth I stopped
on a picture and I go well that's not my
dick
now at first I thought somebody was sent
in my wife dick pics i had that one beat
so I wasn't even gonna say anything to
her you know I mean Mozgov you like keep
looking at that skinny dick babe I feel
pretty good about my son it's not gonna
be as funny when I come out of the
shower doing the helicopter tomorrow is
it is it but then I recognized the IKEA
desk that I had built for my son behind
the dick and I said oh my god I built
that desk and that dick
[Applause]
so I go down into his room on that came
in he goes yeah I go um you'll explain
to me again how the cloud works and he
was like oh you're so stupid and I was
like ya know we'll see I said break it
down for me real slow if you can he was
okay dad
you take a picture on your phone and it
goes to the iPad I'm like what else he
was like mom takes a picture on her
phone and it goes the iPad I'm like what
else he's like I take a picture on my
phone and oh no
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey can I see that iPad and I said no no
not yet he goes okay and then he goes
so how's your day going
I said earlier today not great right now
oh that's good dad cuz you know when
you're in a good mood we're all in a
good mood so and then he said something
that did make me laugh he look he goes
well thanks for stopping by
he tried to pull the Jedi mind trick on
me or some [ __ ]
these are not the dick pigs here I'm
looking for Saigon I think I'm gonna
stick around for a little bit he was
okay what a tree and he said so did you
have a question you wanted to ask and I
said did you have a question you wanted
to ask me and he goes oh sure I'll I'll
go first
oh and I was girlfriend's name's Ashley
right and he goes oh whether are there
any pictures of Ashley's boobs on there
Jacob are there pictures of a naked
underage girl on my iPad and he goes
well not if you didn't see him there are
no
I don't know dude is this and he goes oh
that's just my dick and he said I'm so
glad you saw that what do you think
about that angle I go no no no we're
close we're not check each other's dick
pigs close like that's not what's going
down and I finally had to tell them
behind the other Talent look don't send
dick pics the penis does not photograph
well nobody has ever looked at a picture
of a dick you've been like I love this
picture ever and I saw it like I think I
know I didn't think women react when
they get a picture your dick it's how
you react when you get a boob on their
phone when a teenage boy gets a boob on
his phone they lose their mind there
have been a couple times when I just
heard this from the living room
later taters made you the team dance the
whole thing that is not how you women
react when you get a picture of a dick
right to see though when a woman gets a
dick pic she goes like this cuz she
showed your dick to everybody and
tomorrow it's gonna be on snapchat at
all years
come to my party they don't like that
show anybody who has teenage boys too
knows that they lie lie lie that's all
they do
and you know how you know they're lying
because their mouth is moving they lie
but here's the thing
sometimes you don't bust them with all
of them and sometimes their lies are so
good that you're almost proud of them
you know what I mean you're like and
don't do that again
that's my [ __ ] boy you know my son's
best he ran a game on me
ran a game on me my wife and I we went
to Hawaii for vacation and my parents
came to stay with him so when we come
back we got a DirecTV bill a month later
and there's $200 worth of porn charges
and we're looking at the bill right my
wife and I and I'm mad I'm mad I'm mad
mad right the dude needs to be taught a
lesson because porn is free like how
dumb do you have
I got porn in my pocket 24 hours a day
I'm worried about him as a human being
if he's still paying for porn that is
the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever
heard of I'm worried about him walking
around in this world if he's still
pending for porn like I wasn't gonna do
that I tell my wife I'm like I gotta go
down and talk to him this is so dumb
but here's the deal I feel like this is
gonna be a quick conversation cuz his mo
when he lies is he'll lie and then if
you just show him facts he's like yo
those me and that's it so I have the
facts in my hand I have to build in my
hand so I figure it's gonna be a quick
conversation so I go down into his room
and I'm like hey man did you go Joe I go
you know anything about this and here's
how I could tell he was gonna lie to me
cuz as soon as I held up the bill he
bent over and he squinted like he
couldn't read all of a sudden he was
like
I just started shaking his head like he
had never seen that language before you
look and then he said something so
ridiculous he goes yo I'm not familiar
I'm like what the [ __ ] does that mean
you're not familiar you don't recognize
English sure you don't know what that is
and he goes I'm not sure what that list
of stuff is how Mike gets porn he goes
oh oh you don't know anything about that
farm because no I know you didn't order
that point there's no I know cuz I'm
looking at the dates when the porn was
ordered and it's when your mom and I
were out of town and the only people at
the house were you and Grandma and
Grandpa
so it was either you Grandma and Grandpa
and he looks me right at Minnie goes
well they do like each other a lot I was
like take it easy there man you don't
you talk about my mom right you talking
about my mom right now I said you'd say
my mom watches porn he goes no I didn't
say that you said that and I'm like why
is he so confident I have the bill I
have it right here why and I sat okay
I'm gonna make him so uncomfortable
that he'll admit it and he doesn't want
to talk about porn with his dad so I
guess I'll just start reading off the
titles of the movies so I said to Mike
are you telling me a grandma grandpa
we're in my room watching anal party
three and this is the quote out of his
mouth he goes well the door was shut all
weekend
I thought are you saying my mom watches
anal he goes no you said that I never
said that
guys I walked into the room 100% sure it
was him now I'm at like 99 and then I
realized the reason he was so confident
you know why are you so confident
everybody the reason he was so confident
was the only way I can truly prove that
was him
is it by calling my parents and I say
did you watch anal party three in my
room and on the off chance they say yes
I gotta burn the [ __ ] house down like
I can't live there as an adult male if
my parents are watching anal on your bed
you can burn that [ __ ] down so I need to
I've stopped all of sudden have come up
become Tom Cruise from a few good men
like I needed to know right so I decided
he's gone all in he knows I don't want
to call my parents the only way I can
bust him is if I go all in to so I'm
like okay I'm going all in with this and
I say to him I go man you didn't order
the porn he didn't order the porn and
then he did say what every teenager says
at least once and I said you didn't
order the porn and he's like I wish you
just believed me oh you never believed
me
oh hang on oh man I believe you and he
goes what because I figured I'm pushing
all my chips into the only way to get
him is to admit it is a get him into a
situation that he doesn't want to be so
I said you know I believe you and I
think it's terrible that Grandma and
Grandpa are making you pay for their
born you zag I think that's terrible
dude
I said we should we can't let him hind
the shadows out there in the East Coast
we gotta call him out he was like really
cause I blitz let's what do you think
man and I held up my phone I go let's
just get him on the phone and he looks
me dead in the eye any OHS call him and
he goes no no no call calling dad I want
to hear you call your parents and ask
them if they watched anal party three in
your room I want to hear you ask that
question call I go I'm gone and he goes
I'm right here I was like so I start to
dial one number dial another number and
he goes you don't have your parents on
speed dial and I said yeah I do I'm just
taking I'm going slow him giving you a
chance to come clean he goes oh okay
because I wouldn't say come clean when
you talk to them and I was like listen
guys if this is a fight he's landed
every [ __ ] punch so far and I'm like
okay I'm pressing another button press
another button guys I'm like and then
I'm gonna jump out of a window like this
is it for me
Bob suppress that ninth button and he
goes whoa I'll pay for it
[Music]
and I said you ordered the porn he goes
no that was Grandma and Grandpa I just
don't want you to embarrass them I think
it's nice how much they like each other
[Applause]
it lets me dead in the eye and he goes
we done here and I was like yeah but
that wasn't satisfactory to me guys I
needed to hear him say he ordered the
port right so we get to the outside of
his door and I'm on the outside of it
and I go hey I'm in before it before
before I leave I'm gonna give you one
last offer I will pay the bill and give
you $200 all you're gonna do is say you
heard the point he looks right at me and
he goes nope
grab on grandpa and now every time he
walks by my room and the doors open he
looks and he goes I wouldn't sleep on
that bed like an [ __ ]
I don't feel too bad when I'm doing to
him we're at day three back checking in
back in the fight and I'm started to up
my battle a little bit and I started to
do something in my parent my brother
said to me that I hated
I put vaseline in basically every pocket
that he had jacket pocket pant pocket
anything oh that will drive you slowly
crazy right and I could hear him gonna
bite us all and then it was funny
because my wife calls me into the
bedroom she does you come in here I go
sure and I look on the mirror in written
in Vaseline on the mirror I can't wait
to fight you
and she goes you happy with yourself and
I go yeah sure I'm pretty happy I go he
just wrote a Deathwish Sweden Vaseline
he's ready to snap like he's I'm not
gonna have to wait 12 days he's ready to
go right now right and it's so funny it
really is the bunny's thing about kids
is they they don't think that we
experience what they experience like we
were teenagers we did what you did like
they think oh you wouldn't understand oh
no like he thinks he's the only person
who ever broke something in the house
and just pretended like it ever happened
no I didn't do that you guys never do
that [ __ ]
were you breaking something when you're
a kid you just throw the pieces out like
if there's like that lamp never existed
but like your parents two grown-ups are
gonna walk into the living room and just
notice that that's one of the two lamps
that isn't there that's how dumb
teenagers are they're dumb as [ __ ] I
dropped a keg on a hardwood floor in my
house growing up when my parents were
out of town we had a party it was the
dining room I just slid the dining room
table and rug over nine inches like
Deauville never notice it's the first
thing my mom noticed when she walked in
she was like why is the table there but
how'd you notice she was like I'm a
grown-up now we all know pitfalls of
being a teenager right so you have to
decide which ones you want to warn your
kids about and how you should warn them
you know I think we've all changed how
we warn our kids about drinking and
driving now it's the message is easy
call an uber calling it a lift I'll pay
for everything
wait there's no excuse for it to ever
happen you know and I know all the
people that I don't have kids are very
vocal about that now
and I don't know too many teenage kids
that are drinking and driving anymore
because of that right we're pretty clear
on this message now and but there's
other things that you don't you you know
they're gonna run into that you don't
tell him about because how would you
like my daughter look one of the
pitfalls that I knew my daughter was
gonna run into my daughter my princess
my baby girl the smartest young woman
that I know but I knew that my daughter
my baby girl you know what pitfall I
knew she was gonna fall for you it eyes
news
gonna fall for I knew that my daughter
was gonna fall for just the tip how did
I know she was gonna fall for that cuz
you fell for it and you fell for it and
you fell for it and you fell apart you
don't [ __ ] fell for something if you
didn't fall for just the tip you found
for I just want to lay naked next to you
just one pump I want to know what it
feels like
don't shake your [ __ ] hands you all
found for something and that's what I
knew I like she's gonna fall for that
[ __ ] and by the way it's not that I
don't want her to have sex I'm not that
guy who's like oh I know that's gonna
happen but the tip is where the bad
stuff comes from the tip makes me make
babies I don't want that [ __ ] I don't
want babies I'd rather have a guy say
just the nuts fine dude stuff your nuts
in there I got no problem of that some
nuts I'm in a bit I'm gonna run for
office and you're stuck nuts
it's like feels great stuff nuts no kids
that's all I'm saying
it's so funny to see them do [ __ ] that I
did I remember the first time I found my
son drunk in my kitchen my oldest son
and here's the thing
he was here's how you can tell someone's
drunk you can tell they're drunk by what
to foods they're combining together
because if you're eating chips and salsa
you're not that drunk he was dipping
chicken into peanut butter sitting in
the corner of the kitchen like this he
was like this
but even said I think this is how they
discovered Reese's so I was like hey man
get put the chicken in the peanut butter
down
get upstairs dudes this is embarrassing
here's okay
and he goes upstairs and I was way up
the stairs I said to him mate just so
you know man
not chicken and peanut butter that's not
gonna be good for you later and I was
right because I heard that we've all
heard that right that late-night run to
the bathroom your body is amazing your
body is amazing for this reason you can
pass out as some pert as a man I passed
out Jews have put their nuts on my cheek
they've traced their digs on my forehead
they squirt [ __ ] all over you you don't
wake up but you got a puke and your
body's like and send you off running in
a direction right so I hear running down
the hallway and then there's silence and
then I just hear
[Music]
this isn't fun anymore silence and then
just in my favorite I swear to God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then he did a couple of what I like
to call my favorite the silent scream
you know when you're like oh I feel so
good I don't but your abs never look I
need to do some more of those and by the
way I don't want any one thing feeling
bad for them but things that I do to
them they get me just as much do you
understand that like that's part of the
thing in our family like funny is funny
funny wins and they skit I scare really
easily and my daughter scared me because
I also smoke a lot of weed and and so my
daughter scared me
one time she hid in the front yard so
they know that I come home high every
now and then and she was waiting in the
front yard in a long white flowy gown in
a scream mat I walked into the yard and
she was like and I jazz hand when I
guess got high I make a lot when I jazz
him there's like a million videos they
have a me goal I guess
so [ __ ] them they get everything they
get everything but I knew my son was
getting ready to lose his mind right so
I started to step up my game and I did
something to him that my brothers did to
me that used to drive me crazy they used
to put Tabasco sauce on my fingertips
when I was sleeping well because the
first thing you do when you wake up in
the morning is what you go pee
anybody who's ever touched a jalapeno
and then gone to the bathroom yeah
that's not fun you know so I put the
basketball sauce in his fingertips and I
just wait I wait five in the morning I
get up I sit in the living room and I
hear him go to the bathroom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey is it Hank he goes what does it mean
what what does it mean if your penis is
on fire say well it could mean a lot of
things oh yeah like what like what like
what I said well you could have a virus
and what did it do that appeal the
lawyers what do you do I'm 11 they take
a needle
you stick it in the base of your penis
what be the shot I don't want one of
those what else what else what other was
there any other option I go well yeah I
said with it you could have like a
bacterial infection oh okay what is that
what does that mean how do they fix up I
go well they take a needle and they
stick it in the base you know a shot
well I don't want to is there any option
besides penis shot I love my own I go
with this one the third one but it's so
rare like it never happened do you think
what is it I'm like it just doesn't
happen because what is it is it a Peter
shouting oh no he was told me what it is
okay go it's possible but never happens
but it's possible somebody snuck into
your room and put the baskets on your
finger and he was like I'm gonna bite
you so don't say that don't say that now
look we're buddies we really are buddies
and he tells me everything he told me
and some things I want to hearing some
things I don't
some things are just too much like he
came home excited one night and he was
okay over to ask you a couple questions
I might make him comfortable and I was
like did you not want to ask a friend
he was like Nonna you because you know I
don't want to ask him I get embarrassed
I mean okay here's okay so okay so you
know point out the Ashley up Friday and
we're gonna be alone together we're
gonna be doing some things I've never
done before so I just got a couple
questions he goes we're gonna be kissing
and my eyes are gonna be shut right I go
yes don't be creepy open I kiss a guy
that's for worse you know when you're
kissing somebody and you crack your eye
like this and they're like this and
you're like well [ __ ] tonight's the
night I die I guess I don't know why
you'd be staring at me from an 8 the
bench away you psycho okay I go yeah
dude eyes eyes definitely definitely
close he was good question number one
answered and he goes you don't mind know
what to do here and he's brought his
Brahman was terrible but I didn't want
to tell him how to undo a bra cuz I
looked high school not knowing how to
undo a bra you've got to figure it out
yourself look guys when I want to see
boobs in high school my bra move is this
you know any good number you put it on
top of the titties and it might cut them
in half you're the Garter that's so sad
sound like a man who's you know I know
what to do it no no and then he goes and
then dad and he starts to do this and
he's looking right at me he goes and
then dad and I'm like oh I knew I should
have gotten behind for this guy Reza
walking his fingers down his stomach
then he goes then dad this is exactly
what he said he was then dad this this
is where I hear things get a little
tricky yeah whoever told you that was
right they do again it does he said you
know because oh the lights are on my
eyes are gonna be closed so I don't how
do you like when you have dad how do you
like when you like dad oh he goes let me
start over okay kissing eyes closed
boobies know what to do there take a
walk down the tricky town here we are
and he said what I need to know from you
dad is went like when you're like when
you're with dad would you
this is getting kind of weird isn't it I
do that's a dude we are so far past
awkward I am on suicide watch can you
just ask me the question okay that I'll
ask you like when you're doing it when
you're how would you how do you touch a
woman's Bonanno dad how do you do that
and I was like you want me to tell you
how my secrets I'm not giving you my
secrets no secrets every man in America
we all Harbor those secrets right trial
and error trial there
some [ __ ] with some [ __ ] doesn't you try
but everyman America's come along the
gates even gonna kick you to the finish
line
[ __ ] you figured out like the rest of us
but you don't go from a princess the
sorcerer in one day that's all I'm
saying
pretty sure it's like Harry Potter seven
movies I don't [ __ ] know eight mother
I'm just saying the first time I went
down the girl's pants it would have been
nice if somebody had told me but nobody
ever told me but would have been nice
the first time I went down a girl's
pants if somebody had told me that the
hole was so far back I was pushing
around here for like 20 minutes I'm like
what's the deal is it gonna pop open or
do I need a password for this get a big
little feet let me in
and then when I finally hit a hole I
thought I'm so far back I'm in the wrong
one for sure I skipped over the vagina
and then when I realized that was in the
right place teenage boys are the worst
when I finally realized that was in the
right place I just left my finger there
like I was taking her temperature of
something no movement or anything just
this the whole time
like [ __ ] the Thanksgiving turkey
and I was just waiting harder I think I
might even a lead in it was like does
that feel good
so bad sod like this is right now we're
at the house we're at day 5 and he's
ready to snap after the Vaseline and I
know he's ready to snap so I do the
thing to him that my brothers did to me
that made me snap the quickest they used
to lock me in my bathroom oh yeah for
hours
now I wasn't gonna lock him in for hours
just like an hour and a half so my god
and so when he's in the bathroom I take
some rope and I tie it to the handle and
tie the other part of the rope to the
door ben-tor the door
other door handle and I just sitting
that way and I hear the toilet flush and
then I just hear the door handle and I
get a text
I'm locked in the bathroom so I sent him
a text back I know and then it was just
like in a horror movie all from the
inside of the bathroom all I heard is
are you out there and I said you know I
am he goes you let me out of here right
now I'll break the door down
and I pick up my phone I'm like break it
down has anyone in here ever seen
someone tried to break down the door
some funny [ __ ] the first time I saw I
was in college and my buddy was like I'm
being a [ __ ] out of this guy I go let's
go
and he goes to his house the door was
locked and he was like I'm breaking it I
go break-in and my buddy went in his lip
went because it's a [ __ ] door
everybody that's why they put it up
there so you can't walk in and out all
really Nick if you think you to break
down the door you watch too much law and
order that's all I'm saying
the door so you guys I'm gonna break it
down and the reason I had my camera up
guys is because I'm gonna film it
because I already have my wife and I
have a video that's seven and a half
minutes long of dumb [ __ ] that he's done
that we're gonna play it his way
so I'm like this is gonna be a perfect
perfect video now guys I have on that
video 90 seconds of the best thing
you've ever seen in your life
funnier than anything ever seen on
YouTube funnier than anything you've
ever seen in a movie TV show anything my
son such an excitable just loving life
person even as a young young young young
young boy he rushed through [ __ ] so I
have 90 seconds of a video because we
were playing in the living room and he
went to the bathroom and when he ran out
he was not careful in the bathroom and
he had a little bit of [ __ ] on his
earlobe I have a 90 second video of him
doing this hey you want to play what is
that
[Applause]
you guys saw five seconds of it I have
eighty five four seconds of judgment
it's the best thing I've ever seen in my
life whenever I'm in a bad mood I'm like
throwing the tape like that is the best
thing I've ever seen
so I have it up like this right I'm
ready cuz I know it's gonna happen he
goes I'm breaking it down I go do it and
he goes one two three and all I hears
ooh silence
it's quiet for like two three minutes
and then he comes because I'm pretty
sure this is child abuse
[Applause]
and I said yeah which part he was like
dig all of it silence for like another
three minutes maybe said something maybe
laugh so hard I had to leave the room I
just hear from the bathroom I'm hungry
oh it's like come back in the room and
this is what I knew he started crack he
goes dad dad listen listen if you crack
the door and slip in a sandwich
I promise not to try to get out
I'm like a [ __ ] Stockholm Syndrome
insane anyone is there ago she ate her
with his captors and stuff you know I go
I can't do that man he's like oh this is
what I knew he was ready to fight I just
heard him starting to mumble to himself
oh and then he said this he goes know
when I get out of here I shake them and
I was like [ __ ] I've never been so mad I
was like oh he's ready to fight are you
ready to come out man because your
brother and I go okay and I open the
door you've never seen a bull come out
of a shoot at a rodeo or all their
muscles are moving at once and he's come
and he's like I'm gonna bite you so are
you ready cuz I'm ready go let's go he's
not yet I gotta change into my bike
clothes I'm like what's that so I got in
the hallway and I see my wife Beth and
she's like listen you sure you still
want to fight him I go he just he was
just talking about shaking somebody so
he's gonna fight somebody today so might
as well be me and she said this is
nothing good is gonna come out of this
nothing good even if you win nothing
good comes out of this she said I really
think it's a bad idea and I said what
did I tell you about that I'll let you
know when I have a bad idea and she was
like okay and I go just do me a favor
just put my phone in the window cuz when
I pin him that's gonna be the end of the
wedding video like that's a good way to
go out wedding video over me pinning him
right she goes okay
so I walk outside and when I walk
outside guys I'm pretty happy with
myself for a couple of reasons one I
didn't have to get his violin as my dad
did to get him this bad right into
look whatever you all think about it
nobody in here remembers the stories
about when you were a kid how many times
your mom cut the crusts off your
sandwich you remember the nice stuff
you're like you remember would [ __ ]
Tommy fell off the roof dear Donna day
those are the stories you tell and I
know this is a story he's gonna tell
this is a memory we're gonna share and I
like that [ __ ] when he looks back he's
gonna think man that was funny as [ __ ]
right and I'm happy and then he comes
busting out of the house follow me you
want to know what his fight clothes were
jean shorts no shirt and a bandana I was
like where are you going to chela like
wonder [ __ ] and he comes running at me
throws a punch I ducked it I throw him
over my hip and bam he lands on his back
oh you guys know that noise huh with all
the air just uh and I'm like oh I got a
couple minutes the wind has been knocked
out of them and the first time the wind
gets knocked out of you you think you're
dying right so I'm like oh I got at
least 15 minutes to [ __ ] with this guy
15 seconds or so right so I'm like I'm
always guys I was a huge wrestling fan
huge Randy the Macho Man Savage fan so
I'm like I'm gonna rain in the Macho Man
so I start to walk around I'm like oh
yeah oh man I'm looking in the window
camera like
and then I get a couple more seconds I'm
gonna come off the top rope and I'm
gonna jump on him pull his leg up pin
them into the wedding video
perfect right so I go what you gonna do
when the Macho Man lands on you as
members of her you know her the moment
that's all I had I go to push when I
push this leg slipped when this leg
slipped a disc popped in my back and I
landed right on him and I knocked the
wind out of him again huh
and he's they get off of me get off of
me and I was like get out from under me
and we're both laying there like a
couple of wet mops in the front yard
right thirty seconds later he gets out
from under me walks inside and I'm
laying in the front and just laying
there probably for like ten minutes and
then the front door opens and I see two
feet walking out to me and I recognize
her feet those are my wife's she walks
out and she leans over me just like this
and she goes how do you think that went
I said I think it went pretty well and
she said did it I said I won she goes
did you she said all I know is that he's
inside drinking water and you're still
laying out here with your face in the
dirt he looks like the winner I go yeah
but we're gonna cut the video off way
before that nobody's ever gonna see that
[ __ ] and I said babe
and I knew why she came out she came out
to tell me that she was right and I was
wrong
and she was and I was gonna let I told
her right at the front I said look I
know the you were right and I was wrong
and I'm so sorry and I am the adult and
he is the child and I really just need
to keep that in mind like this is how
your parent we're parent together and
I'm sorry we didn't do this together and
I should have listened to you but thank
you very much for coming out to help me
in and she said I think I'm out here to
help you in she said I came out here to
tell you that the camera is still
running in the window and I think I'm
gonna start a little video mom because
the sprinklers are set to come on and in
three minutes
and as she's walking away I go babe I
don't think that's a good idea and she
turns to me and she goes I'll let you
know when I have a bad idea
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]